Oh
so I feel like there's a connection
between the human desire to lose
ourselves and the human desire to be
enveloped by a technologically mediated
entire like the reason we want higher
fidelity send surround sound the
ultimate you know Bose speakers or beats
speakers we want to raise the caliber
the intensity the fidelity the
resolution of the signal that mediates
us so that we can lose ourselves in it
there's something about the dissolution
of self technologically mediated ecstasy
that we crave it's why we go see
enormous IMAX films it's why we used to
go to the Gothic cathedral it's why
we're chasing these technologically
mediated highs that's why the trope is
associated both with drug binges as well
as with high technology high resolution
high fidelity high human beings want to
mediate their encounters with the other
with logos with dream space and I think
that our urge to create better
technologies is a reflection of this
desire to transfigure eight to have
feverish hunts for rebirth to have
catharsis to have an illumination to
become one
everything to dissolve and to
reconstitute that's just that's what it
means to be us that's the human story
that's what we do and that sum is
reflected in our shopping habits in our
high-tech world